[Music]
we had H3 on yeah yeah for our last
episode is it okay to bring up yeah what
uh the Reddit oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
they hated you guys no so I started
Consulting for them right just like a
couple days a week whatever super chill
super great whatever and
they have this like subreddit where they
just hate on there's like you know
there's like pages that love you and
pages that hate you yes I read it and so
Zach found one where one they got all my
information wrong they're like this is
the owner of Market he's now Consulting
for Teddy fresh I was just checking out
the hype for the H3 episode because I
was excited I was like oh I hope they
you know stay on the zacko elite show
now yeah like I know they're just and
they're like straight talking [__] like
oh my God he's so broke probably he has
oh yeah so one of the comments was on
one of our episodes for the Zack of
elite show or yeah uh I talked about how
I couldn't afford sperm bank for like
one month yeah and like I was getting
like uh what do you call it when they
are about a repo might come oh yeah yeah
I gotta notice saying that they were
gonna like take away my sperm bank thing
so one of the comments in this Reddit
post was like this dude couldn't even
afford a sperm bank and like [__] like
that they're like flaming me in the
comments for his for his Reddit post but
the history of episode was good but yeah
that's that one post I thought it was
absolutely hilarious that I was catching
Strays about my sperm banks
[Laughter]
I end up doing with the second one
because I don't know you only paid off
it's floating around here in space
somewhere you can't afford your come
that's hilarious oh yeah it was bad
that's hilariously man it wasn't even
that much can we talk about how much it
was it was five 500 600 bucks so wait
you're trying to freeze it oh yeah I
froze I had two uh jars worth George
and uh yeah who is licking it who's
licking their fingers this is the
doctors yeah it's like you know when
they put Mentos in Coke
is everything's overflowing yeah
oh it is the joke with people oh uh Luke
enough what is this no don't don't
okay
you seen that [__] where they put the My
Little Pony in a jar fill it with jizz
oh for real oh yeah it makes me gag
every time yeah the fetish thing yeah
you know what they oh that's so gross
sorry I'm just still laughing at that
you couldn't afford to freeze your [__]
okay
hilarious yeah my children are out there
somewhere so you're no they microwave it
dude
the nurses
but they put they put they put a lid on
it we got another one default payment
how was it 45 seconds
the paper towel so it doesn't explode
God bro
well he made the joke
but yeah I couldn't afford it I told him
I'd give it so was your are you
delinquent is it just I I paid for I had
two I could only afford one so I got one
God damn yeah and I haven't checked to
see if they did keep it because I was
getting those repo letters and I paid
for it after like what is the repo
letters look bro they gotta do that on
Discovery Repo Man for semen
I'm just in there begging for them ain't
bad dude from Florida knocked on your
door hey man no please please one more
month hey man give us a cup
give us your cup money he trying to run
away from me right now we got to go in
there and take it
just a jar of [__]
[Laughter]
no how much was to come be honest 500
bucks for a month yeah uh no for a year
500 a year to freeze the jizz yeah we
got to start a Jesus
you guys are the Geezer company and they
had I had the opportunity to not do the
test or the give them ice cream in the
office I could do it from home and then
bring it so that's something opportunity
a cool opportunity yeah way more at home
yeah to lay [__] half a gram of [__]
[Laughter]
yeah
something wrong with it
that's good or bad
dang man I imagine you putting in your
cup holder like come on
oh you hit a bump oh no
ceiling I would cap it yeah okay
obviously you know because you're so
irresponsible yeah damn so you did it at
home and you just drove it over uh yeah
well no I did both of them in the office
so why are you telling us you could do
my home now I had the options to do it
from home but I just did it in the
office
that's a that's a power move man I don't
know yeah
one of them was when during the testings
uh I'd finished so fast that the lady
made a joke saying like wow that was
record time
so no that's like what they say to
everybody maybe right no I finished
really fast I so like I knew that she's
not behind the paywall
but I knew that the date of testing was
this day so I didn't do it like all week
and I I was good to go thank you yeah I
gave it all gave it a mile you prepped I
prepped wow yeah
really proud of that one that is
actually pretty great as sperm bank if
they had a [__] leaderboard
it's like a race track every week yeah
yeah oh my God
that's right there just to be
competitive yeah
you come in just to check like lower the
glasses like huh still on top you guys
see this yeah there's a guy going in
there like can't be that one
so you finish in record time I did you
should have asked her how fast was I I
should have timed it
he just goes in the like the room and
then he comes out the other side like in
like one second all right yeah sure
there's like some Quantum Leap [__] just
like hold on
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like the second the
door closes the other one
Howdy Folks
unreal hours
[Laughter]
I learned from my previous I had the
video loaded ready to go
loaded yeah you watch a little bit in
the car
I prepped yeah shut the
shut up you had a tab open going into
this well I learned because before there
was no Wi-fi so I had to save it saved
it yeah I had to download it and then I
was getting in your photo roll yep holy
[__] dude just filming his computer
screen oh my God yeah I like that dude
in the library
future my family so I had to prep as
well as I could give them my best
medicine
I definitely will yeah yeah there's
people out there just show them the
video on your phone like this is what
put you in the chamber
you look at me funnel for the test tube
baby life yeah could be my my kid yeah
I'm gonna go the old natural way what's
that the natural birth no sex no yeah
you know raw says
how can you go all natural if you're
Frozen well this is just a safety net I
wasn't sure oh God yeah yeah sure got it
yeah the second Blackjack when they're
like you want to buy this insurance yeah
yeah that's called addiction